if you were trapped in a school and
forced to kill your own teacher what
would you do this creature is not human
and these kids are going to have to
figure out the most creative of ways to
kill it if they want to survive i'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat koro
sensei in assassination classroom this
creature is more than meets the eye this
is class 3 and they only have one test
that they need to pass kill their
teacher readying their guns nagi sahir
and the rest of the class shoot at koro
sensei while he reads out the roll call
for the morning this creature has no
known weakness and these students are
going to have to get pretty damn
creative if they want to beat it class
3e also known as the end class is the
lowest of the low the students in this
class are the ones who failed their
final exams to be able to proceed into
the next stage of high school now this
is their only chance at redemption the
classroom is even separated from the
rest of the school to further emphasize
how damn stupid these kids are on the
very first day of class this strikingly
yellow formed creature known as
corosensei introduces himself to the
students the kids are confused by what
the hell is going on so this government
official kurasuma explains that this
creature must be killed for the good of
humanity this creature is responsible
for destroying the moon and will destroy
the earth in the same way by march of
the next year this is top secret
information and only the world's leaders
know that the earth is soon going to
blow up he tells the students to keep
this knowledge a secret or else they'll
face a global panic suddenly the man
tries stabbing koto sensei but his speed
is unmatched getting the better of him
koro sensei takes the time to groom his
hair while the man explains a little bit
more about their new teacher koro
sensei's speed maxes out at mach 20 or
roughly 25 000 kilometers per hour this
means that he could easily leave planet
earth before it gets destroyed to combat
the creature the ministry has produced
specially made bb pellets and knives
which cause extreme damage when used on
koro sensei ok this guy is no joke this
is koro sensei also known as the world's
deadliest assassin and nicknamed the
reaper now you might be wondering what
the hell this creature is his entire
body is made from antimatter which is a
material in the universe composed from
anti-particles they have the same mass
as ordinary matter but have an opposite
charge if we were to see just how
powerful this stuff is one gram of
antimatter could in theory produce an
explosion the size of a nuclear bomb
basically this stuff is made from highly
unstable matter and is volatile as hell
and our teacher is made from this stuff
and unfortunately all of this insane
power comes with even more insane
abilities this eight-legged teacher is
immune to poisons can compress his
entire body and energy into a small
crystallized sphere that is impervious
to harm even from a nuclear warhead he
can regenerate severed limbs possesses
superhuman senses and can travel up to a
speed of about mach 20 and this is just
the tip of the iceberg in terms of
abilities needless to say we're gonna
have to approach this guy with extreme
caution and these students are about to
realize that killing him won't be nearly
as easy as they hope suddenly koro
sensei grabs the gun out of his hand and
detaches one of his arms regrowing it
nearly instantly to the shock of every
student the man tells them to calm down
and reveals that koro sensei here made
an agreement with the government to
never hurt the students this creature is
like no other he tells the students that
he's decided to accept his death as long
as he gets to teach this school's class
3e the government doesn't understand
koro's conditions but either way the
government official informs them that
they've put down a 10 billion yen reward
to whichever student can assassinate the
evil teacher from that point onwards the
kids begin to realize the severity of
the situation and begin to train even
harder to kill koro sensei not only that
though karasuma becomes their assistant
teacher and is joined by a professional
assassin known as irina she's an
absolute badass and is great at her job
but not even irina can cause a dent in
koro sensei's armor failing her mission
she's demoted to a lowly english teacher
for the rest of the semester during
lunch break nagisa here shows his
classmates a potential weakness he found
regarding the colors that koro sensei
switches to and from based on his
emotions his friends tell him it's a
worthless piece of information and get
ready to pull another assassination
attempt in the next class looking
worried nagisa informs koro sensei that
his work is already complete koro sensei
then asks him to give him the work so he
can read it over but nagisa here has
something else in mind in a single
motion he tries to stab koro sensei but
he's too slow that's when nagisa reveals
a bomb attached to his shirt blowing up
and taking out the teacher once and for
all thrilled beyond belief the kids
congratulate themselves on a job well
done however one of them notices the
leftover skin when suddenly the teacher
appears on the roof and tells them that
they've been outsmarted he reveals that
he sheds his skin once per month and
that the old skin took all of the damage
realizing which students did it koro
sensei changes colors and tells the
delinquents that while he's made an
agreement to not hurt anyone in the
classroom he can still kill every single
one of them outside of this room he
tells them that they have a lot to learn
and these students are going to have to
attempt even crazier assassinations in
the near future the next day the
students have corosensei trapped in a
net one of the students shows the
teachers that he put down a dirty
magazine exactly where the net was
placed showing off his intelligence when
suddenly cor sensei spins the net over
and over until it breaks when the
students notice a lapse of focus they
attempt to shoot the teacher but they're
still too slow koro sensei simply swings
himself onto the roof where he tells
everyone that he'll be doubling
everyone's homework as punishment okay
this guy is a hornier bastard than our
very own anime writer sorry dom and this
is a case example of why it's imperative
that we plan our moves more carefully
and that we should always have a backup
plan in place because if we've noticed
with coro sensei he'll almost always be
able to foil our first plan a
assassination attempt but what if we had
a contingent plan b and a plan c and a
plan d you get my point we need to plan
ahead enough so that this anti-matter
education loving monster doesn't know
what hits him an example of how we could
have had a backup plan after the initial
assassination attempt could have been in
the form of when we caught coro sensei
in the net after he got caught he broke
off the basketball rim and landed on the
roof now if these kids thought ahead in
advance they could have gauged that the
distance from where koro sensei and the
roof was was close enough that he could
have made the jump and that the roof in
comparison to anywhere else was probably
the safest platform to land on and high
enough that no other students could come
close to him if we planned ahead they
could have tried placing a bomb on the
roof or left some students in and around
the roof area with the government-issued
anti-sensei weapons ready to go this is
an example of how having a plan b in
place could have potentially worked and
there are a myriad of ways that the
students can incorporate this level of
thinking into all of their future
assassination attempts that's when this
cool looking kid named karma appears on
the scene he and koro sensei introduce
themselves by sharing a handshake when
suddenly koro sensei pulls his hand in
pain karma scolds him and reveals that
he's attached multiple knives to his
hand this kid is smart and the only
reason he's in this class is because of
his violent behavior in the year before
in the classroom koro sensei notices a
dead octopus on one of the tables outing
himself karma tells the teacher he
killed it thinking it was him this
angers koro sensei who promises to show
him the extent of his abilities by
sticking a flaming hot takoyaki into his
mouth later on he and nagisa have a
conversation about their new teacher
discussing who the hell he actually is
suddenly koro sensei shows up out of
nowhere to inform karma that one of his
goals is to improve the skills of his
assassin students adding that he's been
taken good care of based on today's
events karma asks him whether or not
he'd risk his life to save his student
to which the teacher confirms he would
hearing this the student whips out a gun
and jumps off the nearby cliff if koro
sensei comes to his rescue he'll be shot
dead by karuma's gun and if he doesn't
he'll lose his reputation as a teacher
forever without hesitation koro sensei
creates a massive spider web which
breaks his fall while keeping the
student immobilized the student's plans
are ruined again but he promises that
he'll kill him someday soon okay these
two guys here failed in an epic way i
bet karma didn't think of the fact that
if koro sensei tried to save him at mach
speed he would have been dead and if
karma did manage to kill koro sensei
he'd also die from the fall and to top
that off karma didn't utilize nagisa at
all and just had him standing there like
a chump two dudes with one half-baked
plan and you know what i'll go out on a
limb and say that even if we added a
hundred more dudes to this plan the only
thing we would have had is an all-out
disaster because yet again these kids
failed to pick up on the breadcrumb
clues that our favorite teacher has left
for us and that is his love for the
obscene portrayal of the opposite sex i
would have swapped out useless nagisa
for blonde baddie irina and would have
told her to use her feminine ways to
lure cora sensei into letting his guard
down for the sake of humanity of course
all he would ever do is just flirt with
him a little bit and let his guard down
before blasting a hole right through his
brain this way we would have stood a
better chance and we could have carried
out this plan with much better results
meanwhile at the ministry of defense the
government officials worry about the
fate of the earth there's seemingly
nothing that can stop this creature and
if nothing can be done the entire planet
will be destroyed by march the older
official scolds the teacher for not
being able to do anything but informs
him that they'll be sending in a
transfer student as the next line of
attack the next day karasuma introduces
a new student however she's not like the
others she's a female ai robot shaped
like a box whose sole purpose is to take
out coro sensei the ai robot suddenly
reveals a dozen machine guns from both
sides and starts shooting at koro sensei
however even the latest military
technology is no match for his speed
after class one of the students scolds
the ai for creating such a mess with all
of her bullets and that's when it begins
to calculate the percentage of success
for killing koro sensei before
graduation revealing a number of
90.4 percent during the next class the
students wrap chains around the ai robot
to avoid cleaning up her bullets every
time she fires when class is finished
coro sensei approaches the ai and tells
her to try getting along with her fellow
classmates the ai is confused as to how
to do that so cora sensei reveals that
he's compiled data from all of class 3e
students into these textbooks he unlocks
her chains and that night the robot
begins processing the information the
next day the ai appears on everyone's
phones revealing that she made herself
an app to be able to communicate with
each student and support their
assassination plans in the classroom the
students decide to give her the name
ritsu and she soon becomes friendly with
everyone there the students mentioned
that there'll be another transfer
student coming in and that's when koro
sensei enters the room for the morning
roll call suddenly a kid falls from the
roof and immediately sits down while a
mysterious man draped in white enters
the classroom and scolds the kid named
itona for not coming in the proper way
the man apologizes for his actions and
introduces himself as his guardian etona
then gets up and grabs karma by the hair
telling him that he might be the
strongest in the class right now but not
anymore he confronts koro sensei and
states that he is the only one worthy to
beat in this room insisting that they
face off in this classroom straight
after school setting up a makeshift
arena the two face off and the
assassination attempt begins eton
reveals tentacles of his own which
angers koro sensei on the very first
exchange the teacher reverts to the
classic roof trick showing that a toner
here is no pushover the little kid
manages to cut off cordo sensei's
tentacles reducing his speed
dramatically now the probability of him
dying from the next attack has increased
by 60 percent corosense laughs it off
and the little kid goes to finish him
off suddenly one of his tentacles is cut
off by an anti-sensei knife reducing his
powers wrapping a toner up in his own
skin he throws the kid out of the
classroom and ends at the assassination
the man in white takes him away
promising to come back for revenge okay
etona was the one foe who may have stood
a chance against koro sensei as he has
tentacles of his own and incredible
physical abilities on par with him but
he made the crucial mistake of doing
what koro sensei expected him to do
which was to play fair because while
they faced off fair and square etona
missed the opportunity to create a
coordinated attack with his schoolmates
and missed a chance where teamwork could
have prevailed over simply working alone
remember now killing koro sensei is the
ultimate task and the fate of the world
rests on our shoulders i will note
though that atona managed to
successfully cut off a few of corto
sensei's tentacles reducing his speed by
over 40 percent during this crucial
moment where he was on the floor more
injured and hindered than he's ever been
before so far all of their attacks have
been very isolated but can you imagine
if all 30 of them attacked corto sensei
during this face-off because if there's
one thing that likely won't work against
our battle-hardened teacher it's playing
alone and fair and square these kids
need to start playing dirty and get it
together if they want to even stand a
minuscule of a chance of fighting
against this creature with god-like
powers after class nagisa and the other
students asked koro sensei why he
decided to teach class 3e he responds by
saying he made a promise to someone a
long time ago but he can't tell them who
it is the only way to know is to kill
him so nagisa asks him what they can do
to improve their assassination chances
koro sensei suggests that they take
weekend classes naming it the
assassination training camp during camp
nagisa notes down a number of weaknesses
he sees such as his limited efficiency
with after images meanwhile karasuma
begins analyzing each student's strength
and weaknesses for combat however he has
nothing to say about nagisa later on the
boys of the class begin a mission of
their own creeping their way into the
girl's bathroom meanwhile the girls talk
with irina about her love life when
suddenly koro sensei appears from behind
he dashes out of the room before
answering questions about his own love
life while the girls chase him away the
boys realize what's going on and decide
to chase after as well leaving nagisa
behind suddenly koro sensei pops up in
kurasuma's room the man shows him the
results from the assassination training
camp which disappoint koro sensei saying
that it's still not good enough after
training camp a new pe teacher
introduces himself as kurasuma
substitute and gives out free food for
the first lesson karasima and koro
sensei look on while he tells the
creature that they have to find new ways
to assassinate him the new teacher is
instantly popular with the students
however looks are deceiving and this
nice guy is more than meets the eye that
night irina interrupts krasma to reveal
that she knows all about him and the pe
teacher's history telling him about
their intense rivalry she tells him that
he has a history of getting good and
fast results out of his students however
it comes at a cost the next day the pe
teacher gets the kids to do laps around
the school yard when one of the girls
collapses in front of him she tells him
that she can't do this any longer and
prefers curosama's classes angered the
teacher violently slaps the girl before
being stopped by karassima himself he
tells him that this is his way of
discipline to prove his way of teaching
is superior the pe teacher asks qurasma
to pick one of his kids to fight he will
fight barehanded and if the student
manages to even touch him once he'll
concede defeat and admit he's a worse
teacher however the pe teacher adds one
more thing the knife they use will be
real qurasm gathers the students putting
the onus on nagisa to fight in his place
nagisa agrees and the fight begins
nagisa slowly inches towards him pushing
him to the ground and placing the knife
on his neck the student wins and the pe
teacher promises that he'll be back for
more okay while this may seem like sweet
victory this means so much more this is
just the tip of something that could and
most likely will become a whole lot more
serious in the future the pe teacher was
no doubt a self-righteous prick to abuse
that girl student but what karassma and
the whole class failed to realize was
that that pe teacher was humiliated and
power hungry based on how he handled his
role as an authoritative member of the
school and the fact that he just vowed
that he'd be back can only mean that the
next time he comes back to fight it'll
likely be on his own terms and without
any forms of rules to go by which means
we can't let him get to that point
nagisa the girl who got slapped or even
yellow cephalopod cora sensei himself of
all should have recognized that slap to
begin with was illegal and with corporal
punishment in japan being illegal they
should have used that pe teacher's act
of rule defiance as grouse to sue him
and get him off of the grounds to begin
with not that that would stop corto
sensei if he truly decided to kill him
though which would not be a bad option
though if we're not going to kill him
maybe we should go to the legal route
because in a nation that prices
conformity and obedience to authority if
the students don't act now then they'll
further encourage this behavior which
will lead to more future problems and we
already have our hands full with trying
to take on corto sensei we don't need
any more problems or distractions headed
our way the next day one of the students
asks koro sensei to drink a poison she
made suddenly his face begins to
transform and turn white however it
doesn't work during the next few days
cora sensei plays around with the kids
showing off new and improved powers to
the students the students begin to get
angry and have self-doubts telling that
koro sensei that he's too good to be
assassinated this angers the teacher
beyond belief who tells them that they
don't have what it takes yet to be an
assassin and he asks all of the class to
gather in the schoolyard with everyone's
attention now on him he asks the
students whether or not they really want
to kill him he asks the professional
assassin if she only plans one attack
for an assassination she tells him that
a proper assassination with detailed
backup plans for any possible scenario
is a must moving to karasuma he asks him
if the first strike is the only
important one when using a knife he
responds by saying that the first strike
is likely to be dodged so follow-up
strikes are even more important than the
first koro sensei tells the kids that is
the utmost of importance that they
continue studying in case he disappears
or even worse dies that's when he jets
off circling right back onto the
schoolyard with a giant military weapon
he tells the class that if he doesn't
see any improvement of the students he
will simply vanish he reminds them of
the poison incident telling them they
need to be more deceptive if they want
to have a successful assassination a
successful assassin is well-rounded in
every sense of the word a word that
they'll soon find out the importance of
very soon later that day corto sensei
tells them of a goal that they must
achieve for the end of term exams each
student who receives a top score in a
subject will be allowed to destroy one
of his tentacles losing even one
tentacle will drastically decrease his
speed and reduce his ability to create
after images making their assassination
attempt a whole lot easier excited
beyond belief the class gets to studying
after hearing the good news okay if i'm
these snotty-nosed kids then i'm not
sure what the hell they're doing they
gotta study koro sensei down to his
daily bowel habits this is a case
example of not putting in the extra work
to study after school hours as well as
during these kids should be following
quarter sensei around the clock
everywhere he goes throughout town as
best as they can observing him at school
only tells them one side of the whole
story and this is something that the
class should take into account if they
want to have any chances of killing him
at all we should round up the entire
class and get them to help us and above
all we need to make sure that we don't
get caught in the staff room karasuma
tells them that the class's academic
skills have drastically improved koro
sensei agrees saying that the students
need to be fit not just physically but
mentally if they want to assassinate him
later on corto sensei surprises one of
the students and tells her that he plans
to improve her english skills through
first-hand experience suddenly he grabs
and sends her around the world to learn
everything the world has to offer before
they know it the day of their exam
results have arrived announcing the
students scores they realize that with
the amount of top scores they have the
ability to cut off six tentacles the
students are thrilled and they get to
work making the final trap to
assassinate quarter sensei once and for
all that night the class watches the
fireworks from the roof wondering if
they'll really be able to kill cordo
sensei the next day suddenly cordo
sensei himself shows up wishing the
students luck in their assassination
attempt now the day has finally arrived
the students get their anti-sensei
weapons ready for the assassination and
reveal a massive trap with the sole
purpose of killing their teacher the
kids tell koro sensei that they plan to
cut off his tentacles and slow down his
movements afterwards caging him inside
water to finish him off surprised koro
sensei asks the students how they knew
about his weakness to water and karuma
reveals that he found out to do to him
bloating up when the weather was humid
and rainy on the count of three the
talking ends and the action begins the
students began shooting at cordo sensei
cutting off his tentacles next they
throw as much water as humanly possible
onto the creature in the midst of the
chaos two mystery men shoot corosense
with anti-sensei bullets creating a
massive explosion which shocks all of
the students okay it seems as though
these students unlike the previous times
actually put some pristine thought and
effort into their latest assassination
attempt which honestly is quite a
refreshing surprise but it still sucks
hear me out as we know with koro sensei
nothing with him is as it seems and i
would have used all of my cards in our
final assassination attempt that was
taking place because if we remember
nagisa was taking notes and noted down
the behaviors and patterns of koro
sensei and since this is the final
assassination attempt i would have used
the other two known weaknesses of koro
sensei first the anti-sensei material
and second some questionable magazines
because why in the world would the kids
set up this perfect assassination
contraption and not use every trick in
their book to defeat koro sensei for
example wrapping quarter sensei up in
anti-sensing material like this guy had
on earlier before chopping all of his
tentacles and not just six because
anyway you slice it the only way to
fight fair against this overpowered
balloon head octopus would be to fight
dirty now i may be an expert on pretty
much everything i know i don't care what
you say youtube comments but i'm
definitely an expert on telling a bunch
of kiddos their plan is not exactly all
the way thought through confused the
students awake to see koro sensei gone
and they can't believe their eyes
suddenly they see him in a shallow
puddle now in the shape of a sphere
quarter sensi reveals that this fear
that he's in is crystallized
high-density condensed energy meaning he
can't be affected by water or
anti-sensei substances karma attempts to
shoot him but it's no use in this form
kordo sensei can't be hurt however the
form will only last around 24 hours
karma suggests that they cage him up in
a pool full of anti-sensei material but
koro sensei tells him he'll just explode
again breaking the cage and setting
himself free the students are
disappointed and suddenly some of them
begin to pass out that's when a jeep
comes rolling in and the pe teacher
jumps out with his squad lackeys he's
back for revenge and none of the
students could have predicted him being
this petty the pe teacher reveals that
the students are passing out from a
toxin that they drank and that they only
have three days left to live once
infected and he shows that the only
antidotes are with him this is
diabolical as hell and these kids have
no idea what hit them but before we can
address this fully we should understand
the psychological response to the act of
fainting which can come about due to the
stimulation of the vagus nerve this
nerve is responsible for the regulation
of internal organ functions such as
digestion heart failure respiratory
failure as well as vasomotor activity
which refers to the actions upon a blood
vessel which alter its diameter this is
a reason that can cause the heart to
slow and blood pressure to drop
drastically however it's important to
note that not all losses of
consciousness are related to the vagus
nerve now the cold hard fact of the
matter is is that we can't get rid of
the poison from our systems if we don't
know what poison is being used but the
pe teacher is the only one who knows
what poison it is and he's the only one
around here with the cure on him however
the pe teacher made one final mistake in
his threatening execution he stated that
the poison delivered to the students
will kill them within three days that
means we actually have time to kick his
ass and sad to say but the price of all
of these students is worth the
possession of quarter sensei not being
in their hands because let's face it our
yellow octopus friend at this point is
basically a kid's toy-sized b-41
hydrogen bomb which means we can't
afford to hand them over and like i said
even if they don't make it no kid is
above dying for koro sensei because the
world is safer if he's in our possession
than the bad guys sometimes you gotta
make harsh choices in life kids furious
at the incident with nagisa he tells the
teachers only to give him the antidotes
in exchange for his arch nemesis qurasma
approaches nagisa who is holding koro
sensei in his hands koro sensei doesn't
believe that the pe teacher is truthful
telling him that something is off about
the negotiation suddenly a tentacle
appears out of nowhere attacking nagisa
and karasuma climbing above the jeep is
etona who's gained complete control over
his tentacles wanting to be the
strongest he chases after nagisa and
karma who is still holding koro sensei
in a ball meanwhile the pe teacher
laughs at their misfortune saying that
he'll be the one with the 10 billion yen
while he gets back into the jeep the
teachers look on helpless with no way to
harm the man because of the antidote
still on the run koro sensei tells
nagisa not to worry about the others and
only focus on stopping etona meanwhile
the class is treating the unwell
students who are currently in critical
condition however while they might be in
the school they're not as safe as they
might think nagisa and karma continue
the chase up an electrical tower when
suddenly a tentacle slashes the ladder
they're climbing on separating nagisa
and karma to free his hands nagisa
throws cordosense to kanama but is soon
confronted by itona he tries to run but
he can't escape he's restrained by the
tentacles and uses koro sensei to hit
him away using the beams he continues to
climb while avoiding the tentacles until
getting hit down and injured nagisa
manages to make it onto the platform
while etona slowly walks towards karuma
the boy admits his defeat and tells
itona he'll hand koro sensei over to him
that's when he kicks the ball over to
nagisa making etona even angrier he
demands that they give him what he wants
but his powers are about to disappear
because suddenly it starts to rain
heavily causing antona to cover up in
fear nagisa hugs the boy forgiving him
on the spot koro sensei realizes that
the students decided on this day for the
assassination because of the heavy rain
he tells yutona that he should stay in
class e in order to become a better
assassin and asks if he would like to
join suddenly the boys get a text from a
fellow classmate telling them that
something bad has happened back at the
school arriving at the schoolyard nagisa
is greeted by the pe teacher who demands
that he hands over the sphere he has one
of the females captured and plans to
bury her in cement if nakisa declines
the offer he continues to push nagisa to
hand koro sensei over reminding him that
he has the antidote to the virus but to
the pe teacher's surprise nagisa pleads
for him to be the one to kill koro
sensei however the teacher doesn't agree
and stomps nagisa's head down to the
floor nagisa smiles and hands over koro
sensei however it's a fake and the pe
teacher takes out a ball that's when the
rest of class 3e comes out from the
school building all with guns in hand
moments later the pe teacher and his
lackeys are restrained with no way of
getting out coro sensei congratulates
the students on their hard work and the
ai robot reveals that she's already
found out the formula for the antidote
meaning everyone is safe looking above
the students see government vehicles
coming to the rescue what it do weebs
i'm an albert here so albert tell me
what did you think of assassination
classroom well first off there's a
reason why we did the live-action movie
and not the anime and you can find out
why in the pin comment down below so my
main problem with the live action movie
was that it tried to adapt the anime too
much what i mean is that the story
structure is all over the place and each
point are disconnected to each other but
the visual effects are really good the
characters are funny and koro sensei is
a giant perv carlos sensei is a horny
bastard but here's the thing the guy
never dies i don't know what the writers
were smoking when they came up with this
dude but props to them because you just
can't beat them you really can't but
overall great story a lot of heart and
yeah back to the show in the government
facility harassment tells everyone
they've developed a shelter to save
earth looking towards the monitor corto
sensei gives the class a final message
congratulating them on their progress
all the while being buried in
anti-sensei bullets on the count of
three the government announces that koro
sensei the destroyer of the moon has
been killed leaving the students in
tears suddenly a yellow hand pops up out
of nowhere revealing the message to be
untrue koro sensei is still alive and
well now back for the second term the
kids continue their assassination
attempts however there's a much bigger
threat waiting for them in the future
and if you don't want to get wrecked by
no suspicious looking yellow tentacles
then like comment let us know what you
liked and of course didn't like it don't
forget to check out the holiday playlist
down below